Yeah, hello, hello, hello, I put on a skin suit this time,
not longer naked anymore, guys, I'm, I'm wearing clothes
again, I'm wearing my skin suit this time, oh, shit, wait,
let me change the flag, uh, I forgot, I knew I forgot
something, I had a little bit of dissociation session, all
right, let me boot up the broadcast, uh, I have
Switzerland's flags already, so I just need Argentina, uh,
Argentina, flag i'm back guys last watch along of the day um
and then after that it'd be semis when is semis does anyone
know when semis are uh i know like the last match finals is
on the 19th that's what i know because i was looking up
finals tickets just to see how expensive they are and they
were like what they were like what i told you guys like the
hospitality tickets were crazy um the 14th oh it's not too
bad on the 14th all right uh let me change the flags uh so
we have like four days before the next match next couple of
matches all right where is argentina oh there's a tiny
argentina flag right there and then england will be
switzerland where's switzerland where is your flag oh i
watched it live so i should have oh yeah i forgot i don't
have switzerland's flag because i watched it at the stadium
just to watch haramba for four hours of my life all right
let's see i don't have switzerland's flag
oops uh saved in the wrong area it's fine I know the Brits
got me who I think me who is the curse doll guys everyone
talked about the vtuber but I think I think me who is the
secret curse doll she was she was the real curse all along
every country that held a me who died like felt fell
every one of them
England's next she's been marked it's like the grudge
England has been marked The sisterhood of the traveling Miku
It's the new Annabelle He's been marked for Knockout Simple
mind They have a super chat Thank you, doke I need you to
root for Argentina so they can lose I need Switzerland to
win, please Well, I need Switzerland to lose Your country
didn't get knocked out by Switzerland.
I had to see sad Colombians at the stadium.
Guys, they were so happy.
I had to watch I had to watch so many people cry.
I felt so bad.
In person.
I had to do that in person, too.
You know what the worst part is?
You know what the worst part out of all of this?
I had to watch Harambaugh for four plus hours of my life in
person, live.
It's not like I could turn the channel because I was in the
stadium, live.
I had to watch, look at Harambaugh.
That's the big, that was my biggest gripe out of all of
this.
reps are Canadian let's go we never forget that was the
biggest sin that they gave me making me watch Haramba in
person and now I get to watch more oh goody yippee oh yeah
my timeline is like so FIFA coded that all I see on My
timeline is just yaoi now, bro, of Holland and Jude.
People were like, like, Holland, please stop.
The mega ceremonies are going crazy.
They're distracted.
Sorry, my go-ah.
Oh, fuck.
Hello.
Can you guys still hear me?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I actually fucked up.
No!
Ah, okay, there you go.
I fixed it.
Okay, sorry.
I accidentally pressed...
Oh, my gosh, no.
Do I have to refresh this?
There you go.
I accidentally...
Because my GoXLR is actually European.
Ah, shit!
Everything's going wrong.
Oh, no.
I have to reset.
Okay.
Alright, there you go.
I got the timer up.
Everything's going wrong right now.
Oh, wait, we did not win.
My GoXR is European.
So, if I touch it, I have a little adapter.
And if I touch it a little bit, my GoXR goes fucking crazy.
And it resets itself.
That's what I get.
Simple-minded.
They have super chat thinking thank you.
Two of the referees are Canadian.
The games are already rigged.
The script's been written.
I already saw the script, guys.
yeah basically my because it's like because like European
European like I guess like plugs does not go well I guess it
doesn't fit my adapter is a universal adapter so it goes
crazy for Europeans because it's like super loose when it
comes to European plugs so if I touch it a little bit it'll
reset itself they know what they were doing
simple-minded they give it to their super chat thinking
thank you I am one of the refs too I'm out there I was one
of the script writers they invited me to the boardroom
they're like only Canadians are allowed in the boardroom to
write the script that's how we got to round of 16 I saw so
many tweets about how disappointed they were about the
Norway because apparently FIFA made an official statement
they made an official statement being like the ball did not
touch the wire so the goal counted but the thing is I think
like Fox News posted a clip about it being like showing like
close-ups of the ball hitting the wire I thought that was
and if everyone was like the best player was the cable
yeah yeah I mean, it literally dropped down.
If you look at the replay, like the Canadian broadcast
literally showed the replay of the ball instantly dropping
down.
It was crazy.
Yeah, the cable, because they're like, the ball can detect
even like a slightest hair.
So it's not our fault.
Our technology is solid.
It's like when everyone's like, you know, when people are
like, the AI is never wrong.
us so you're wrong you know when they all rely on like they
rely on like technology to like do their uh judgment and
stuff but like they don't use their eyes their fucking eyes
anymore i'm like bro like we have eyes like we all have eyes
and then like they're like they're like uh yeah but
technology is not wrong i'm not rooting for anybody i'm
rooting for someone's downfalls i have a four out of four
success rate um including last game including earlier
today's game with uh norway versus england i currently have
a four out of four success 100 win rate
uh four out of four every country i rooted for to win has
won technically
where is this being played right now guys i know all games
are in america right now so where is this being played
i still think it's funny that it's supposed to be like you
know america u.s canada and mexico and then canada gets like
16 games i don't remember how many games like mexico got And
then America got like 70 plus games and then like And then
like, yeah, and it got 16 And like, hey, everybody, we're a
team How many
games did Mexico get?
Mexico got good We're like the little brother Yeah Hey, but
we are Yeah, oh Mexico got 11 Wait, less Wait, how many That
got wrong How many games did Canada host for World?
We had to be similar.
It wasn't then.
It was.
Oh, 13.
Sorry.
We got 13.
How do we get more than Mexico?
How do...
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Oh, that was a good shot, though.
I'm just surprised we got more than Mexico.
We had 13.
It's hot.
That's true.
Playing Canada.
At least, like, we're, like, up north.
Oh, Mexico also got 13.
Okay, someone said 11.
I was like, there's no way.
There's no way we got, like, more than Mexico.
Literally, like, us, because, like, if you guys didn't know,
host countries get an automatic...
Oh, hey, look, there's Messi.
Host countries get an automatic...
What's it called?
In?
Into the World Cup.
So we don't have to do, like, qualifying matches.
We get, like, an automatic...
Guarantee in I don't remember what's the word for it What
did he do?
He just kicked the ball at him Yeah, automatic entry Yeah,
so like any Any country that hosts The World Cup Oh, he had
a ball Why was this ad there?
What the fuck?
He's like playing Paddy Kick with a ball Um, I don't think
it was super chat.
Thank you.
Rue against England, entire nation of Ireland would be most
supportive.
Thank you.
Rue against Mike and Doki getting it right.
Thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
I was like, what was that?
What was that call for it?
What foul was that?
He was getting ready to the fall.
And he was about to grab his leg before he kicked the ball
into his hand.
Oh.
Okay, there's no, there's less Haranbaugh right now, which
is good.
Okay, this is the most aggressive I've ever seen Switzerland
being.
Thank God.
What was I talking about before I got distracted by the
handball?
Oh, good defense.
That was a good defense.
Oh, I forgot to click live now.
Oh,
yeah, yeah, the cannon got free-placed.
It's like 13, 13, 13 games from both Mexico and Canada.
It's also like middle of summer right now, so it's like
pretty bad right now.
Pretty bad, like heat-wise.
What?
Another corner kick.
Okay.
I will say, I have not seen a lot of Swiss people in the
stadiums.
I think it's just like...
I think just because the tickets already got bought up.
That was a fast goal.
Nine minutes.
That was clean.
That's actually clean.
That was a clean goal.
I'm not gonna mention what I saw there.
That's a fast and very clean goal.
Haramba can't save you now, bitch.
Doki, why is your...
I'm, like, literally right next to a stadium right now.
I'm in Kansas City.
Yeah.
I traveled to Kansas City.
Just...
He, like, that guy, he gets good.
He's good at head, guys.
That's a good head.
Good head right there.
That man knows how to...
ahead oh yeah points this one that was the the first good
head I've seen in the World Cup who guys I saw the script I
do think if finals being France versus England would be much
more exciting than Argentina versus France but that's
because like there's like you know there's a hundred years
more than a hundred years of history in the making for that
the most intense rivalry in history just
the amount of history that comes with that match the
most heated of rivalries
oh shit what happened I
see oh shit oh oh my god oh my god he bounced wait that guy
fucking ricocheted the floor I didn't even think it was
possible he actually ricocheted he got scoombas stamped no I
don't think it's a red card guys you can walk guys it was on
him he did it himself guys shall I was the scripting oh wait
Let me read something real quick.
Yeah, I think Switzerland deserved that, you know.
In fact, he tripped the Argentine football player.
In fact, let me read that real quick.
Yep, yep.
He should have got a red card for that.
Big fam that's totally unbiased commentary.
Don't read my description, guys.
Purely unbiased, by the way.
Yeah, I mean, it's on them for wearing a red jersey, you
know?
Like, that's going to get me confused.
That's going to get the ref confused, you know?
You're like, I see red.
Does that mean red card?
It's like, you know, like, when you're, you know, like,
what's that sport called?
What's it called when they're like, but the red cape and
stuff, and they're like baiting bulls, rage baiting bulls?
He touched the ball!
Red card!
Yeah, Matador?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like a Matador.
They're like rage baiting the refs, you know?
They see the red on the...
Look at that!
His body was on!
His body, like, pushed the Argentine player right there.
Yeah, yeah, bullfighting.
Did you not see that?
Bro, what the fuck was that Switch player doing?
Backing up into the Argentine player.
I am enjoying the game because there's less Harambaugh right
now.
Like, they're actually playing the game, which is nice.
We do not get a lot of murder ball.
Oh, my God, that pass.
Oh, dog.
Oh, he fucked up.
That was a really beautiful pass earlier, though.
Oh, fuck am I watching?
Just, at least, just punch each other at this point.
Like, ha ha ha ha ha ha.
If I swear to God, if I...
Ooh, nice, nice juke.
Oh, that...
Those passes earlier was beautiful.
They just fucked it up at the last pass.
I feel bad for Norway, though.
Like, half...
their team was was recovering from being sick and they
couldn't delay it and it was so hot and humid too in miami
whose idea was it to have it in miami i feel like i don't
know i feel like especially with the temperature right now
you you should like have it like hosted in cities more up
north versus like i don't know florida miami in the middle
of summer yeah in July like oh I don't know if it was like
not July maybe or an indoor stadium that's crazy to have it
in like Miami Florida in the middle of July with 40 plus
degrees and being next to the ocean by the way Nick like
next to the ocean where it's humid as fuck
like it wouldn't mind if it's like there's like places if
it's hot but not humid that's fine but like humidity plus
the heat oh my god what the fuck wait an error occurred no
why was there an error okay never mind it's back I had an
error just now it's like they caught me saw me next day saw
me watching from like um from like outside the stadium and
then try attempted to kick me out
is this can't how hot is kansas city right now it can't be
like that human in kansas city though
oh 29 yeah 23rd that's like 10 degrees lower than um lower
than what it was Norway versus England game.
I feel bad for both.
Norway and England are not good with heat.
But then England had time to adjust with the Mexico game.
Because Mexico game was also super hot.
Right?
And when they were playing against Mexico.
Oh.
He can walk.
The leg didn't touch him.
The slide didn't touch him.
I'm watching on TSN because on Canada you can only... What
the fuck?
What was that?
What was that pass?
Bro!
She was trying to get too jiggy with it.
That was like...
Bro, the momentum was so good.
And he's like, yeah, but watch this.
Pass this to the enemy team.
Yeah, that's pretty cool, was it?
He footballed a little too hard.
He wanted to get clip farmed.
He wanted to orify right there.
I wish we could watch.
I hope maybe.
Oh.
Nice kick.
Where is he?
Whoa.
He fast.
He's fast as fuck, boy.
Is it offside?
He ulted too hard.
He literally was just playing like.
He just was playing pass with the goal key.
I've done that before.
I've goalie kicked it just to pass it to the goalkeeper.
To the enemy goalkeeper.
Oh shit, wait, whose ball is that?
I can't even tell.
Oh, it got his arm.
It got his arm.
Handball.
That was a handball.
Or armball.
Must be nice in air conditioning.
In that air conditioning room with your fucking suits.
Oh, it's 50-50 possession.
Better than 60-30 earlier.
I think, like, Switzerland has really good defense.
But I don't know against Argentina, though.
Switzerland is very strong defense-wise.
And, like, stalling.
This is the most aggressive I've ever seen Switzerland be.
I mean, that's why Switzerland is, like, been neutral in the
wars because like if you guys didn't know the reason why
Switzerland had the privilege to be neutral and also didn't
really get invaded or anything is because they were like
surrounded by mountains so it was like Switzerland was just
hard to invade in general because they were just like in the
middle of mountains and terrain
so they're very used to they're very good at they're used to
defense alright hydration break time.
They had natural cover.
They still shot planes down, though.
A little fun fact.
Even though they were neutral.
They still shot planes down.
Yeah.
They're like trespassing, but we're neutral.
Neutrality doesn't mean you can still trespass.
They just wanted you all to be like, off their lawn they
just shot down any plane you know they didn't shoot like
they didn't play any favorites they shot down any plane
doesn't matter which side you're on
I don't know what would be I feel like I don't know about
hmm well who would France be playing guys who is France
playing against next because it would be like most likely
what statistic wise it'd be Argentina versus playing against
spain right spain i haven't watched any of the spain games
what's the power level of spain what's the power rankings
does anyone know the power rankings of spain spain is world
number three but france is better
very boring but strong okay Spain is three France is two
okay so I guess that would be a fun game to watch because I
didn't I've never I haven't watched any of the Spain games
so I wasn't sure how good they are um so that would be
interesting to even watch I mean we gotta know where Miku's
gonna go after so we gotta see if the Miku curse we Let's
see if the Miku curse is actually Oh, hey, they're back on
the field Hydration breaks over It's going to be in fact So
I want to see if they Will they'll go to Argentina or not
I swear I feel like Mr. Bright They only had rights to Mr.
Brightside
Once they're in the museum They stay there
British Miku
express VPN damn I would assume oh Home Depot whoa whoa Home
Depot got two ad space
wait does Spain play has its place infinite triangles and
has no finishing it's very possession based as long as it's
not Harambaugh I'm happy
to sponsor one of the World Cup shit.
It must be a lot of fucking money to be on those little
rows.
Hey, it could be Chad.
You're right.
It could be Chad, Miku.
Haramba, but upfield.
I think that's much more interesting than Haramba in
general.
Anything.
Anything is more interesting than Haramba.
Oh, oh, that was a good defense.
a good steal all right that could not hurt what okay the
Paul stand the fuck up bro that guy that could not hurt you
that was like that was the lowest line like what do you
where are you grabbing
where the fuck are you grabbing that wasn't even where the
where he hit you like get the up bro like that was the
slowest collision of my fucking life
i can go what did he like i can go fucking gave you like the
fucking like charles xavier brainwave scan on you or some
give you the like trauma beam on you and you fucking fell
down.
You, like, touched the wrong part of the leg where he
fucking collided on you with.
Like, he did not even hit your goddamn knee.
Look at the goddamn shin guards this man has.
Like, his fucking leg is wrapped in, like, plaster.
Alright, back to the goalie.
And the goalie will pass to the right and then the right oh
oh he's not he's not gonna pass back to the goalkeeper oh my
god what is this new patch notes just dropped for
switzerland oh back to center and then where is he gonna
pass it to oh he's gonna pass it to the right oh my god he's
going forward he's going forward guys the goalkeeper's
behind you guys the goalkeeper's right behind you No way!
Well, they can't stall anymore because it's 0-1.
They have to make a shot.
What the fuck was that pass, bro?
Well, anyway, who's that?
I love when they, like, pan to, like, famous people.
I'm like, who are...
Oh.
Good seal, though.
That's a good seal.
The Harambaugh patched Yeah, we have nerfed Haramba.
Okay, Argentina is resetting.
What the fuck?
He uses the enemy team as a passer.
That's crazy.
That's football right there.
What the?
Okay, that was an insane pass.
He literally used the enemy team as a pass.
Oh my God, what are these?
Oh.
Come on, come on, why are you still in?
Why did you stop?
Just run!
The ref's in gone!
Oh, come on.
All right, give me the replay.
Give me the replay.
What happened here?
Yeah, like, what the, like, wait, why did you put your hands
up?
Why, just keep playing.
Keep playing until the ref blows.
I literally paused.
Bro.
The man shot my family in front of me.
Oh, trauma.
That's crazy, bro.
That guy, good acting.
Good acting.
The acting class is paid off.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck was that fall?
What was that fucking fall?
That's crazy.
Give him an Oscar There should be an Oscar for football Ten
out of ten He almost believed it too I almost believed the
push I almost felt like the man pushed him With a car I felt
like he got ran over by a car That exact moment
Did you see how built out those Swiss players are built guys
one touch is like it's like what is it called when you like
break like head trauma it's like collision with a car going
70 miles per hour
yeah cte
oh that's not a great pass though i think argentina has
really good defense so far they've been able to like still
It's like good defense and also Swiss have been giving
really shitty passes Because some of these passes were like
So avoidable like some of these passes could have been like
So avoidable like why the fuck did you pass through the
enemy team?
What happened here?
Nine years Sam.
He's been footballing.
Oh.
Damn.
That's got to hurt, though.
That's got to sing.
Slay it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The RG continued equivalent to let's fucking go is.
I'm always scared of saying something in a foreign language
because I get baited so easily, so I don't know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What?
Wait, who got the file?
Oh, okay, you got a file.
Vamos.
It's safe.
Okay, thank you.
You guys are like my... You know how, like, in medieval
times, they would have a guy that eat the food so they don't
get poisoned?
You guys are my fact checkers.
You're my at chat GPT.
a gamer word where's
my yellow red cards guys come on I demand yellow cards what
the fuck the guy got a soccer ball thrown at him at that
from what did you guys see that somebody threw a ball at him
where did that second ball come from yeah you're my vars
guys The funniest bar incident was the fact that like the
guy's dick got was like too big and got caught by bars.
It spawned off screen in just a glitch.
Yeah, I was like, where did that bar come from?
Yeah, his bulge basically passed the bar line and then they
called offside.
And they broadcast that to like everyone around the world
and be like, like, yep, there it is.
the offside you must have got a lot of ladies after
was it edit god i don't say that i want to live it i want to
live in a world where that is real i shall i shall ignore
what you say and continue to live in my blissful ignorant
world where the virus technology deemed a man's bulge too
big and considered it offside I choose to believe
if I believe hard enough it is real
oh my god what did he do?
they shank him?
typical Swiss player
look I saw it did you see the knife?
he put it back in his pants after bro did you see that he
pulled out a knife
i don't know it was really fast but don't worry i have the
gamer eyes i saw my my eyes went 0.3 speed holy this the the
swiss had so much possession this like i said this is the
most aggressive i've ever seen the switzerland play
the fucking stadium.
I why couldn't they play like this?
Why couldn't it play like this when I was in the stadium?
Legitimately like I- this is what you could have done This
is literally how you could have played and then you decided
to play like pussy shit when I was there in person like
Yeah, I believe it.
That makes me angrier knowing that they can play like this
and not giving me that privilege makes me more what was that
fucking pass bro yeah you better get that ball back you did
this i hope they score i hope they just to punish you like
that that was absolute bro bro what the fuck were you doing
bro he deserved to get scored on to live with that mistake
So you can live with that trauma.
That pass was absolutely terrible.
He's like, what the fuck did I do?
Yeah, I wish they scored.
That was such a bad...
That pass was fucking terrible.
I'm so insulted that I had to watch that.
This is the team that eliminated Colombia.
like columbia passes were so good oh my god they just had
shitty follow-up with it they like set up such insane plays
and then like oh my i want to see that again i love watching
the passes from columbia it's crazy to watch
shooting the boss would be so funny oh my god what the fuck
was that That was, bro, are you serious?
You got the foul, like, gifted to you, and you shoot it out
of, off, like, out, out of the boundary.
Like, what?
What is the, who, where?
Where the 12th person was going to be there and fucking
jumped in.
Like, your 12th person was Superman.
Like,
like, like, at that point, just, like, you shoot the ball
into the man's crouch.
babies anymore at that point you might lose but at least you
know no yeah you go out knowing that that guy can no longer
have kids like better than what the fuck I just saw at least
I would get content he's counting on the 12 ghost player
fight fight fight yeah stay on the floor 20 minutes longer
It's about to go out.
Nico, thank you for the raise.
Thank you, thank you.
They thought Lynn was going to come out and just be like,
I'm your twelfth player now.
Oh, my first yellow card.
Okay, what?
Oh, what?
It's like a dry fire.
What the fuck did I just?
It's like, pop, pop, pop.
literally rolled down the window while the car was going he
killed him holy shit i was literally a fucking drive-by the
guy didn't even stop i just witnessed the crime he didn't
even stop the window was like the car was still going like
pop pop and then drove off
That's crazy.
That was a crazy foul.
Can't stop.
We got a trade.
Bro, I actually got a trade.
Can't stop the a trade.
That was crazy.
I think that was my favorite foul so far.
No, that's not true.
That's not true.
Holland pushing that guy on the ground was my favorite foul
so far.
There it is a hit and run.
No, because in a hit and...
Oh, wait, it is.
Yeah, it is sort of hit and run.
No, my favorite foul has to be Holland fucking playing a
fighting game in the middle of the...
During the corner kick.
Only I score.
Holland angry.
haught me one fall me all down the guy he's through had it
coming
all right four minutes yeah there shouldn't be it was just a
hydration break mostly all the fouls were quite fast
you're right there has been a lot of really good fouls the
guy that was alting during the Mexico Max was also really
funny too he's like I'm gonna I'm gonna What the fuck
happened here?
There's so many cause There's has been already I will say
What bro Okay that should not have been a foul Bro didn't
even see Bro just decided to be like Love chat There's no
That should not have been a foul That I will say This This
match Already doubled the amount of fouls in norway versus
england yeah it's already this game has already doubled the
fouls and we're only like we just started at half time we
were if not tripled it's either doubled or tripled
oh what is this the swish guy should have stayed on the
ground and then they have to 50 50 who to give it to because
if you get up too fast then you'll just they'll just think
like oh It'll go to the guy that's still on the ground.
Okay, no, no, that should have went to that.
No, his leg was below him.
What the fuck?
His leg was below him.
His leg was below.
Was it not?
That looked like a Argentina foul.
I think it's because Swiss got up too quickly.
If he stayed on the...
If he stayed on the ground longer, then they had the 50-50
in.
if he got up too fast bro bro what were the acting classes
for what were the fucking acting classes for guys
oh my god what's the point how are you gonna win the Oscar
how are you gonna win the Oscar bro it's because it's the
first time This is their first time in the quarterfinals so
like they never they didn't have they didn't get acting
classes before They're like it's like they're just like in
the amateur theater right now and Argentina has won like
five Oscars already Oh my god, Santa ground stay on the gas.
Yes, that's right You know what he learned he's learning the
guys improv is guys.
He's improv good improv good improv he's learning he figured
it out he gave the system he realized he has to stay on the
ground they're improving the Swiss read the patch notes he
learned the meta he realized yes and they're learning on the
go.
Alright, half time.
Okay, let me set up the time.
I'm just happy that Swiss at least is, like, not making me
go through a third game of Haranba.
We know this meta doesn't work, guys.
It's because Neymar didn't have, like, his entire team.
team you know with him you know if his entire team started
flopping maybe he would he would win yeah i do it as a team
guys you can't just be one guy because then people will get
you know people are gonna be like it's weird that you keep
falling but if the entire team joins in then they'll be like
you know what maybe maybe maybe they are getting injured
The whole team's gotta commit to it a bit
Alright, I'm gonna need to order food for dinner Let's see I
had Jolly Bees today for lunch So what should I...
Bro, I keep...
Guys, my algorithm's a little fucked
My algorithm's a little fucked them is a little it's a
little it's a little up right now I'm not surprised uh all
right so I'll show you guys one of them let's see let
me see I could find it
let's see where
the fuck is this
wait I think my algorithm changed wait oh my god okay all
right it's okay my algorithm is now different I think it's
my phone my phone algorithm my PC algorithm my PC is all
about Holland and Jude and and but then my phone is like
normal all right so I so this is why I get on my PC these
are the tweets I get on my PC and then
and then this is the this is the shit like I have heated
rivalry shit on my on my PC right now
and then and this is the one I'm getting
what the fuck is this
and then this is what I'm getting on my phone algorithm let
me see if I can grab it And this is why I get on my phone.
And you pull up my phone.
This is my phone.
This is my phone algorithm.
What the fuck?
He's flying a kite.
And this is my piece.
algorithm and then this is this is why I see on my PC and
this is what I see on my phone
oh never mind never mind my phone has changed my phone
algorithm has changed guys not
and it just like got my sorry never mind the algorithm has
changed and it's like it on my phone it's
not my fault guys it's not my fault someone hacked my
algorithm
Alright, back to ordering my food.
I mean, ordering my food is totally...
Guys, I got hacked, guys.
I got hacked.
My algorithm...
Someone's algorithm is on my Twitter feed.
I don't know how this happened.
Okay, this one's good, though.
This is a good fact.
Oh, the goalie was, oh, apparently the goalkeeper was like
crying, apparently, right after the game.
Oh, that's so sad.
The goalkeeper was so good.
I think, like, uh, like he literally blocked, like, three
shots, three shots, and then it was the fourth, like, was
it, he blocked two amazing shots, and it was the third,
like, in a row, and then the, like, he just, you getting
caught, couldn't get up in time for the third one.
If he was, he could have got one second early who had
blocked it, but that's not on him.
Yeah.
He blocked in crazy-ass shots, too.
In the one where he blocked two in a row, and then, um, he
blocked two in a row, and then, um, and then there was no
defense to help him with the third.
And then their best, was their best defender?
The one that was been helping him got, like, knocked out of
the field because of an injury, too, like, midway.
like not even midway like the last the first uh the first
like 30 minutes of the game
what happened to my algorithm
guys i don't know what happened to my algorithm guys guess
someone hacked my algorithm what happened
all right i have to order food now all right let me see i
don't know what to get so i had i had uh jolly bees for
lunch so i need to figure out what to eat for oh my voice is
dying i'm becoming like kane right now i'm gonna sound like
i'm gonna sound like bert from chemistry.
I like to have had a great game, honestly.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Someone hacked my algorithm.
I blame Elon Musk.
There's a breach in the data center.
Did you guys hear that one of Mark Zuckerberg's AI databases
is leaking chemicals into food or some shit?
I don't know the exact thing, but my friends was freaking
up.
There's apparently a lot of like Restaurants have to change
their ingredients for food because like if it affected like
produce and stuff Did you guys hear about it?
Yeah, it's like Mark Zuckerberg's like AI One of like their
AI databases leaked like bacteria From the cooling water
into like
Into like the water stream or some shit So they have to
change a lot of ingredients.
But it's only in America for now.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it leaked introduced the bacteria into the water
supply.
So a lot of crops are getting viruses now.
But it's okay.
It hasn't affected Canada yet.
Yeah.
We're safe in Canada for now.
the data centers are turning crops yay oh no how are we
gonna Elmo what are you doing here Elmo I'm getting Elmo ads
I'm trying to decide what I want to eat what I want okay
there's Korean there's ooh There's like a fusion place
Our morning food right now I'm still trying to decide I want
to eat
I wonder who Elmo is rooting for I remember when USA was
playing And then he was like Go US but also I want all teams
to win
1934 That's crazy
Panda Express?
No.
How dare you say Panda Express?
Sorry, guys.
I'm ordering food for those who are confused during
halftime.
I'm, like, trying to figure out what I want to eat.
But I also disassociate a bit, too.
It's been a long day.
It's been a really long day for me.
Ooh, I could get, like, those old...
Omo rice.
Omo rice is always good.
Then they have like this.
They have like a stupid buy one, get one free promotion.
I hate wasting food.
I would order it if they didn't have a buy one, get one free
promotion.
Because I know I'm not going to eat the free one at all.
Like I just want one.
Like bro, I'm just trying to order one.
I don't need another one.
You don't need to give me another free one.
Oh, you know, I'm going to get the, I'm going to get, I
mean, I could get Katsu.
Oh, I like Katsu.
You know, I'm going to get Katsu.
Oh, no, the game is about to start.
I don't want to pee now.
I'll pee it during her duration break.
We'll rock you, yeah, rock you.
We will, we will rock you, yeah, rock you.
a big mistake we will we will rock you yeah when they do
hydration break i'm gonna do a reverse hydration break
actually i don't really want katsu i'm not like that i don't
know fuck it i'm gonna get katsu fuck it i'm gonna do it or
unless We will rock you.
We will, we will rock you.
I'm ready.
Two, one!
Go!
I mean, 1-0, though.
Pretty decent.
Oh, I know what I want.
I know what I want to get.
I need to find a restaurant, though.
I forgot what it's called.
I mean, I feel like Switzerland always had pretty good
defense in general.
They've always been super strong in defense.
But, like, and they've been, like, super aggressive now.
But also, their passes have been, like, pretty meh.
I'm not a huge fan of their passes.
Well, they don't need Haramba yet.
They just need one goal, and then they can Haramba.
Or two, honestly.
Maybe two.
Oh, shit.
oh you're not gonna fall down now you're not oh you're not
gonna fall after that bro
at any point of time you should be falling is when that ball
oh was that not painful oh you're walking off now oh now
you're gonna walk it up
but that was I heard the fucking explosion like I like you
guys heard it right Like, we could hear how hard the ball
hit, too.
Oh, good pass.
Good pass.
Good.
I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying.
Switzerland's passes are fucking ass right now.
W pass.
That's what they're trying to do, right?
Pass is a goalkeeper, a goalie.
Holy shit.
risky bro that that i don't think that was worth it that was
so risky why would you pass oh now you decide yeah now you
decide to pass the other goalkeeper get get past there why
would you like pass that's i don't know some of the decision
making is really ass
yeah that was so fucking risky oh my All right.
I was going to say, because I felt like if he hit that shot,
that actually, I don't know.
I felt like that, I just, I want good goals, you know?
I would be like a weak-ass goal if he hit that.
That would be such a sad goal.
Because like, where was the D there?
What?
That was a really good defense.
Oh my God.
that it was a good setup too
was that foul or what it's either a corner kick or a foul
that was that was crazy that was it I like good football I
just I like doesn't matter this oh my god that that pass was
beautiful holy shit between the legs
oh my God, this is what, yeah, that's what Sorloff could
have done.
That was, holy shit.
Between the fucking legs.
I love me some good football.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Almost.
I think we juked him.
Who is Sorloff?
Is that, was this his first World Cup?
He didn't see Holland.
There's no way Holland was like, PASS!
You know?
There's no way he wouldn't have been vocal.
There's no fucking way.
You don't even need to see him.
He wouldn't have called it out.
That like, it was that...
Like, how do you not see...
Also, by the way, how do you not see Holland?
Like...
That man is, like, taller than everyone.
Not even, how do you not see a John fucking Norwegian tank
build liking?
Was that Sorloff's first time in the World Cup?
Yeah, Bro is built like a goddamn brick house.
Oh, it is his first time.
Is he younger or older than, uh, younger or older than, uh,
Holland?
sucks though like he has like a lot of haters now because of
it because of the one mistake he's made he might have like
done a lot in previous games but because of this one mistake
that's all he's like known for now where he fumbled like
all it takes is just one just
one mistake
he's just like reposition guys guys oh he's stalling He's
just like, give me a second.
Let me think about it.
What a fucking goal pass.
That is a beautiful pass right there.
All the way to the other side of the field.
Oh, good pass.
Good pass, too.
Right into the goalkeeper's hands.
Good pass.
Bro, these passes are crazy.
I know, right?
It's like, look, those passes to the goalkeeper are insane.
I think Messi's going to retire.
He'd be like, what, 44 in the next World Cup?
Or what, 43?
Oh, 43, right?
I think, I don't know.
I feel like at that point, because when you're 43, that's
when your joints are going to start, like, I feel like it's
going to be harder to keep up.
How old is LeBron James?
I know like basketball and like soccer is different because
like basketball you're running less compared to like oh that
cross just don't oh 41 yeah because even like because it's
hard to tell because like uh but like you could tell like oh
oh is he okay
want to use the bathroom while he's down like i don't know
how long it's gonna take guys
i fucking called i was like i don't know how long it's gonna
take i'm just gonna use the back i fucking called it i come
back and it's over i didn't even they haven't even started
oh there we go i fucking knew it and this is my first time
watching an argentina and i like argentina play how long
he's gonna be on the floor for I'm gonna use the bathroom
I had a feeling
Oh did he kick The shin guards And then broke his toes Wait
did he actually got taken out
I feel like this World Cup Has been the craziest so far In
terms of like upsets Oh yeah Yeah Well, they knocked out one
of their defense players, then.
Oh my god, what the fuck, bro!
Like, even...
I don't even need to hate watch you.
Yeah.
I don't even need to hate watch Switzerland with him playing
like, bro, this is...
I had to beat Lost Camp.
All those passes, man.
All those passes, and they just forgot how to pass to each
other.
like my god what was the point of doing all those passes for
what
happened is the only one you can only take one guy at a time
he has a limit he gets overwhelmed when there's more than
one grab him grab i want to see him he'll fall again I want
to see.
Let me try this place.
Is this the place I usually order?
No, it's not.
There's the place I order.
I still haven't ordered food yet.
I've been so indecisive.
I'll try this.
This is a new place.
This is a new pasta place.
What was this shot?
I looked down while looking for food.
Was this a good shot?
Oh, that was a good save.
Good save.
That was actually a pretty decent save, too.
Keep going.
He's going to get up.
I will say, I'll let you guys know right now.
I don't know what... I can't tell where Messi is.
They all have the same hairstyle on the field.
So I legitimately don't know what...
Like, looking at this, I don't know where he is.
is on the field i like i don't can't tell like it's like
where is number 10 bro they just started tackling each other
what the fuck they're like ref didn't call i did not hear no
bell we go again i just saw four tackles in like 10 like in
five seconds
gets the foul i can't even tell i saw like four fucking
tackles
bro he's like i didn't hear no bell round two bro they need
to give me the replay of all those tackles i saw thank god
we finally get murder ball hey that's football
i've been thinking of a super chat thinking thank you I see
messy guys.
I found him.
Wait, where is he now?
There's two of them.
There's two messy.
If they take up, if their jerseys had no number and I only
saw the back of their head.
It's like where is messy?
Oh, why?
Good pass.
Good pass to our to messy.
You wanted to pass to Messi, guys.
Who's this guy?
I guess we'll never know.
Every time they panned a famous, someone famous, and they
don't tell me who they are, I'm like, who is this guy?
Why is he here?
And W passes.
That was a really early goal, though.
Wait, does Messi have kids?
I'm curious I
mean he's 40 he's almost 40 right you should yes wait what
does his wife do is his wife also a a football player
oh that was a good save though his wife is a baddie all
right this is more important apparently Messy.
No, I'm just wondering.
Is he like, you know, is he growing more messy babies?
You know, like.
Oh, the childhood sweethearts?
When Messi was nine?
Oh, that's cute.
Oh, they're not, they're not, she's not a, she's not an
athlete.
Because I was going to say, are they trying to create my god
that was a beautiful save that was a beautiful save good
save good save yeah but imagine if his wife also played
soccer though imagine he could have made like it could have
been like holland where they literally uh grew the perfect
football child like it was genetically engineered to play
imagine imagine it messy married and at like another
football player and then genetically engineered like the
perfect football player just imagine like Holland Holland
was technically like genetically grown in a he I would not
be surprised if he was grown in a lab
like like his his dad was on team Norway and his mom is flon
or some shit like he she was made to run his dad was made to
run and kick but his mom was oh my god holland's kids are
gonna go crazy oh my god someone needs to i will not be
surprised the moment a big oh my god wait there's already a
baby he's already a father that child that child already has
sponsorships i will not be surprised holland literally
followed into his oh my Oh my god!
What?
A goal!
My god!
But a crazy shot while I was on my eugenics talk.
But...
Holy shit!
I did not expect that goal either.
That was a crazy goal.
Holy shit.
One to one the plot advances
yeah messy needs messy just needs eight more kids oh my god
wait that was that was a beautiful that happened so fast too
holy shit that that was insane in that angle that's a hard
angle between the legs I didn't expect a goal because that
was such a hard angle.
So I didn't expect a goal from that.
Oh, that's great.
That's crazy.
That was an insane goal.
Anyway, back to my creating the perfect football player.
Because I was thinking, like, how does this literally
continue?
continuing the he's continuing the cycle because like
Holland was literally like One of the perfect like they
started with Holland, you know, because his dad was on team
Norway and his mom is like a fucking athlete too So like and
then like he started playing football since he was a kid
stay on the ground stay on the ground Holy shit.
They pushed him fight fight fight.
It's hockey now Fuck it.
We're back in the Stanley Cup keep yes.
Yeah
Bro already got a yellow card and they still want to punch
him.
Oh my god, I forgot.
I forgot I was doing a watch a lot.
I thought we were just hanging out.
I forgot to change scoreboards.
Fight.
Anyway.
I mean, I can't be mad at Swiss for that.
shot that shot was beautiful like i legitimately did not
expect them to score uh i didn't expect them to score at all
but fucking the close-up between the legs insane that was a
beautiful shot like i i appreciate good like you know i like
good football anyway so so and then for those who don't know
holland's girlfriend slash wife is also a Like, they met
when they were teenagers, and they played in the...
Oh, they're doing...
They're VARing right now.
The VAR room.
Okay, but he did touch him, though, so I don't know how this
works.
He was touching him!
Yeah!
VAR is checking.
He got touched by his aura.
Man, touched nothing.
Bro, he's just, he's just learning, guys.
I like the replay.
Replay.
Keep replaying.
The Swiss?
Oh
my god.
I feel like I'm watching a Bollywood film right now.
What?
Oh my god, he's gonna cry.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Oh,
that's the drive-by.
Oh.
That's crazy.
I didn't even forgot that.
I forgot that that was the...
Okay, but the drive-by.
But he did do the drive-by, though.
I forgot that was the A-train.
Yeah.
They're not allowed to do any sub-train.
right that's
insane that that's crazy now we're getting extra haramba
till the end during the during when if it's one-to-one if
it's one-to-one do they get to get 11 in yeah I know it's
like down to 10 but I was thinking is there like a timer so
like so like dude if if it's like If it's like 30 minutes.
No, they can't put in an 11 player.
Oh, they have to haram ball.
They can't murder ball anymore.
Oh my god, bad head.
Bad head.
All right, who filed?
I don't know.
I feel like we've tripled the fouls.
I've lost track on all.
I feel like I spent 90% of this game watching foul cameras.
like it's been like it's like 90 minutes i've just been
watching the replays of foul cameras i don't even know like
where how what is the what's the number of fouls it's
offside okay just a wide dive at this stage of the game cool
spot thank you the super chat thank you thank you do you
think it was like um like do you think it was like because
obviously like it was just a little tap too what's good go
ahead thank you super chat thank you thank you i feel like
i've been at files every other minute i can't tell anymore
hydration break i know i was like hydration we're gonna get
like a 10 plus minute we're gonna get fucking 10 minute uh a
10 minute timer additional timer i
just the first time i saw like a yellow card getting revoked
because of var i didn't i never seen that before like for me
watching from watching
why didn't we get var from the england versus guys all right
but the england versus norway game like why did we get a
yellow card for that though that one deserved Bro, okay, if
anything deserves a yellow card.
It was when we saw, like, the England versus Norway game
where that guy, like, fucking tripped over from air.
Like, yeah.
And that was so funny.
You're right.
They're better actors.
England had better actors.
That's true.
That's where the BAFTA is.
England is one of the big best...
One of the countries with the most famous actors.
That's true.
Some of their actors are knighted.
The England...
England does have a lot of really good actors.
We paid $1 million for all the grandmas.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They are pretty good at it.
Oh yeah, Tom Holland, bro.
I love the fact that...
Holland got DM'd by Tom Holland from the Spider-Man films
that they wanted to like meet him for dinner and stuff and
then uh and then uh Holland was like who the fuck is Tom
Holland I don't know who this guy is and then like ghosted
him and he found out later that he was like a famous actor
and he's like sorry I don't know much about actors I play
video games like he was like I don't watch movies I play
video games game so I don't know anything about actors.
That's insane.
That that was, I felt like I was watching a fucking soap
opera there.
Seeing the card being pulled away and swapped over.
That was insane.
And they're like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Cyclone, thank you for the Akka Sufa.
Thank you, thank you.
Everyone's so scared now.
So Swiss is so scared i mean understandable that's just
crazy
do you hear that they were like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa but
i wish i got i wish they gave a card i felt like that
deserved it more than like i mean it was both bad like they
both died but the fucking that one didn't even get called
for anything that was crazy all
right gambling on penalties swiss won the last I don't know
how good Argentina is on PK, but I saw the Colombia versus
Swiss PK.
Wait, which side?
I've lost track on which side is which.
Okay, this is the Argentina's goal.
So I don't know.
Is Argentina good at PK or no?
Oh, I think I hit Swiss at the end.
I don't, I mean, the Argentina goal.
goalkeeper seems really really good yeah i i'm like judging
like just watching the argentina but the switzerland
goalkeeper one player of the match uh for the colombia game
oh they're haram balling with 10 players is so risky though
i feel like no i will not be surprised of his 20 minutes of
extra time there was so oh my god bro what are these passes.
I don't even want to watch anymore.
like, they don't even need me to hate watch.
Like, what the fuck are these passes?
Like, it's so, ah, I just hate, I hate bad passing.
Like, I hate bad passing when the passes are, like,
literally right there.
Like, it's literally right there, and then you still pass to
the enemy team.
Like, you don't, Like, no, Canada was not very good at
passing at it.
No, don't worry.
I've watched it.
I saw them piss-poor football when I was watching them play.
It's...
Our goalkeeper won us World Cup in PK.
He's a rare pee that's good at catching penalties.
Penalties is so hard.
Like, because, like, you have...
It's, like, prediction.
It's not even, like...
Uh...
It's like, yeah, I was going to say, um, penalties is like
more about predicting because there's not enough time to
calculate because the ball goes so fast.
So it's more so like you're trying to predict where they
might go, like instantly.
That's why you see goalkeepers go left when the ball went
right because it's just bad prediction.
Everybody's so scared to get another foul.
It's for Argentina to be really bad to get a red card.
Because obviously they need their players for, um, Oh, oh,
oh, what a steal, but then you just position them better.
What a fucking steal.
Oh, no, no, no, no whistle, no whistle.
Oh, stay on the ground.
You can stay on the ground.
Everyone just stay on the ground.
It's just going to be plus 10 minutes anyway.
Press plus 20 minutes.
The bus has been parked.
In penalties, Argentina, the Go-Kia have an observation.
What is that?
Something I don't know.
Or no.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Everyone just start dropping.
We have so much time.
Just everyone just start falling.
Oh, it's a one piece thing.
Thank you.
I see.
Everyone dropped dead.
Not yet.
There's some.
Seven missed.
Because they're down one.
Possession has been like hard on Argentina's side.
Because one player will always be free.
Which is bad for them.
Oh my god.
There is a.
What?
Oh it's offside.
Okay, it's offside.
That was close.
Oh my god, what a fucking save, but offside.
What a save, though.
Good pass.
Yeah, that was a good pass.
That was a good setup.
But it was offside, unfortunately.
You know what?
I haven't had...
Hold on, I've got you fine.
In a long time.
I'm going to grab that.
Hold on, I've got you fine.
I haven't had in a while
What's the difference between dark meat and white meat
I'm I've been getting distracted It's one to one Those games
are tight
Dark meat has a lot of blood Which is better Dark or white
meat Dark is more juicy Alright I'll get dark meat
Alright I got my food I finally ordered food You guys, you
proud of me?
I finally did it.
Great beverage.
And this.
I don't think it saw another 30 minutes, though.
Honestly.
Oh, shit.
Good steal.
Okay.
You can't do a good steal in a fucking absolutely horrid
pass, bro.
what's the point
what the fuck was the point like what was all the haran ball
for what was it all for
i don't know either oh oh oh he was like oh that's where the
ball's going mr broken bond thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you Okay, I know you said every game you
watch, you pick one, but Canada didn't even win their game
against Switzerland.
No, every game, every team I've picked to do a watch along
for has won, including the game, including today's game in
the morning or in the afternoon.
I did not switch teams.
I've always been rooting for England.
As a Commonwealth country, I was always rooting for my
fellow colonizer.
Meep, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I just had a big Chimichong as about to pass.
Oh my god, like they've been passing in this game.
Thank you for the super chat, meep, thank you, thank you.
out of four our king guys guys our king is the is a is is
the king of england what are we supposed to do our
head of state is technically is technically the king of
england
looking for an er etsy which the curse of argentina Mega,
thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's a royal decree.
Oh.
Bro, that 10 out of 10 v 11 is really hurting them.
But honestly, like, I mean, England won when they were 10 v
11, though.
But Argentina is like, statistically, Argentina is the
stronger team.
But it's all statistics.
Statistics has not helped the World Cup so far.
I would say Like I said, there's been a lot of upsets.
There's been so many upsets in this World Cup in general.
A lot of teams that are considered favorites have gotten
knocked out already.
I know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's extra time now.
Nine minutes?
Yeah, they need to defend for 30 minutes.
30 minutes.
I don't know if they can defend that for 30 minutes.
Oh, oh, this is.
Oh, nine minutes.
Oh, it was with Argentina possession.
Yeah, no, I said that at a time.
I was so surprised it's nine minutes.
I felt like it would have been a 20 minute at a time.
Yeah, the red card seemed to, like when they, the red card,
they were arguing for, no, I feel like, I feel like it could
have been more.
I felt like the...
I felt like the red card alone added like at least five
minutes.
And there's been...
Guys, I feel like I saw like triple amount of fouls in this
one game compared to the England versus Norway game.
I feel like this has been like at least in the 30s right
now.
I feel like I have to...
I saw 30 fouls.
Oh, Argentina has possession again.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Oh, hey, free ball.
Oh, he has so many options.
This guy's been choking.
This guy's been choking his shots.
He had, like, it's 10v11, and that guy has not been, like,
that guy's been handed, like, At least seven shots.
Yeah.
Like every...
Like, it's one guy.
He had one guy on him.
Holland had, like, eight.
They called people from the stands to start blocking him.
Like...
I feel like...
I felt like they called people, called fans to run down the
field to start marking him.
This guy on the left has one guy.
I did my part.
Did he though?
Oh, there you go.
He's got another pass.
He's got a pass.
Oh, he doesn't believe.
Oh, he's got another one.
Oh, he doesn't believe anymore.
Oh, well, it's not equal anymore because it's 10v11,
unfortunately.
I think when it was 11v11, the games were much more
exciting.
I'm just watching a pass central.
I'm...
I'm just watching them play hot potato.
They're doing subs now.
They're playing time.
I mean, with 30 minutes, it is a lot more.
It's a lot more opportunities.
I don't think it's going to get an extension.
I don't think so.
There's not...
I haven't seen, like, any fouls during the extension time.
I've seen, like, a lot of...
Okay, goal, goal kick.
It's too far.
That's been close.
But, like, if it was, I think, obviously, if it was, like,
11v11, this game would have been more exciting.
The game was so much more, it slowed down a lot because,
like, you know, Swiss can't do anything about it.
They can't do anything about it.
This is all they can do.
They just have to slow it down.
They're like, I think they're, like, praying for PK.
I think they're relying all this on penalties right now
Because that's like the only chance they have
Yeah, it's their best shot So it's so slow down No,
Argentina's been like in their fucking home Like in their
field Oh, was Embalgo their main attacker too?
Oh, why would Oh, no, yeah for him to, like, dive there.
I didn't know Imbalo was their main attacker.
Oh, that was such a beautiful pass.
Holy shit.
He has to do a prediction now.
It's okay, he can push him because they're outside the
goalie.
This is such a sail, mate.
It is.
That's what I'm saying.
I felt like England should have got, like, a red card or,
like, not a yellow card For that one dive where he got
slapped by the invisible Norway player.
You know?
Like, if we're doing that, we should have barred the England
versus Norway.
Because that was bullshit.
Like, I was just like, what the fuck was that?
Like, the guy got slapped by a mosquito.
They're like, Messi!
I liked how...
I think, oh my, oh!
What a save!
Holy shit!
Also, I think it's really funny when, um, that was a that
was a beautiful save.
I appreciate good saves.
Alright, they sent it to that guy who can't fucking do any
shots.
They just don't have a main guy at the top because the guy
got called out.
Yeah, their goalkeeper is good.
Oh, this is scary.
scary I actually don't I don't know if I can watch this
actually oh oh whoa the heads oh my god ten seconds left ten
oh foul oh
this is intense this is it this is intense and awesome
they're hiking like hey bro look at them They're playing a
different game right now.
Those two.
They're like...
Those two are playing a whole new other game.
All right.
30 minutes.
The long game, you might say.
Yeah, those two were very close.
That was it.
Oh, yeah.
Apparently, I just found out about it, but apparently, like,
whenever there's like a, what's the word?
There was like a trend where, is that trend?
What's the word?
There's like a tradition where every time they get messy,
where they get messy into doing a commercial, he doesn't
speak any English at all.
He just says, see.
I think that's funny Rangie, thank you for the rate I think
I've had a good stream Thank you I saw the Spider-Man ad for
it Apparently he does that for all ads He just doesn't speak
English
Alright, I need to get water My water I'm gonna be right
back guys I need to go get some water real quick
I'm back Oh, back in town for the coin flip No, I'm back
guys i was trying to find water and i couldn't find water so
i just i just grabbed a bottle and filled it with tap water
i made it back though i'm back i'm back in time look they
had half time i had half time all right what's the timer at
is it 45 i don't remember there's a 30.
one hour 30 right It should be.
All right, here we go.
I ran out of bottled water, so I was like, all right, tap
water.
It's all right.
We're not in America right now with the bacteria thing and
the water supply.
So I think I'll be okay.
I'm Canada.
We're a little bit further away from America.
All right, start.
It's ready.
So this actually is just parking the car right now.
They have a tank in there.
2, 4, 6, 8, 9.
Where's the 10th guy?
Oh, it's goalkeeper.
I forgot.
The goalkeeper is a person, too.
I was like, where is he?
Holy shit.
Oh, that's crazy.
Oh!
Well, that would have been such a good shot, too.
Like, goalkeeper have rights too.
Oh, Messi's doing a corner.
Football unites the world.
Oh, my God.
That's like...
Oh, you can tie air with these.
Yeah, free ball.
How nice of him.
Bro, that was so nice of the guy.
Oh, my God.
Look, he gave the kid the ball.
It's so nice of him to do that.
What a good guy, you know?
Good for him.
Wow.
So humble.
Pass the...
What a great pass, guys.
So wholesome.
Good pass to the child.
Wait, the ball has like the...
What is it?
The ball has like the trigger hit stuff, right?
To know when it's touched or something.
The sensors, right?
It's the ball itself that has the sensors.
Oh my god, that kid's gonna be a fucking thousandaire.
No.
Good pass.
Good pass, bro.
Yeah, the ball is bugged.
It's gonna listen to you.
The ball has the sensor.
Paul's gonna lear everything.
They would give him a replica.
Just put in a bag.
Oh yeah, they'll just...
Each ball has a GPS tracker.
Fiva's gonna dox you kid.
Bro, this is...
Oh, he slipped.
They can't do anything.
There's only 10 of them.
Or technically not...
Yeah, nine of them.
I...
I'm so...
Okay.
This entire game is just on Swiss field, but I'm just I'm
just watching them play four square I'm gonna say a four
there's like There's like 20 of them in this square I'm just
like I think this is four square This is 20 square I this is
so I'm sorry.
I'm so bored.
I am so bored
it's it's just
it's like who is the king of the four square is the
goalkeeper the goalkeeper is the king of four square
like keep away keep away oh that was intense shot that was
that he put all his energy in that shot too
holy shit That was close.
That was close.
That was like an intense shot.
He fucked up his ult, guys.
Oh, they can only have one more sub left.
I told you, Swiss is so good at defense.
Like, I feel it.
Oh, nice pass.
Nice pass.
Good pass back to the Swiss.
Good for them.
Giving them...
Alright, who tripped who?
He's like, me?
Wait a minute.
Me?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, definitely me.
Bro, you should not be...
Even he was like, bro, what the fuck?
Yeah, yeah, that was...
him officer that that was it
it was just a hug donkey was just trying to give him a hug
they're like oh my god oh
my god he got it too friendly
oh yeah no that's goal that's a goal kick bad head bro he
did a takedown he fucking did Jesus Oh God I'm surprised
none of these people have concussions right now What the
fuck
Wait is that another yellow card
Oh Oh they're playing super Oh my god and then he grabbed
his leg right after He's like you're still walking You're
still Another one Holy shit A back-to-back, baby.
Guys, guys.
FIFA just realized all their offshore bank accounts were in
Switzerland.
They just realized.
And they're like, wait a minute, guys.
Guys, wait.
The bank just called us.
They just...
They did a hot fix right there.
You're right.
Argentina just wanted to make it fair.
Oh, I mean, they're just doing everything they can right
now.
Oh, wait, God.
Yeah, they're writing a hot fix right now.
They're patching it live.
the switch.
I swear, I'm going to fall asleep.
Nice pass.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If you don't realize how much thank you for the super chat.
Hats off to the script writer, though.
What a script.
I must have read like a previous draft of the script.
The red card was was a plot twist that i missed the board
meeting for
five minutes still second half i liked one hollyham sweet
you said a half time and it's half my time see i didn't like
them i didn't like any of them that's on you mr mcfluffigan
stay with super chat thank you thank you the algorithm knows
hey why did you like it huh why did you like it
Oh, it's very open.
Oh.
Oh, but that's on Argentina, right?
Yeah, that has to be Argentina ball.
No tomato for this match.
Oh, my God, this fucking wall.
I'm going to fucking, I'm going to explode.
Oh, my God.
We spend 90% of our time watching this.
Oh, whoa.
Oh.
It's in Messi's range.
What a...
Oh, my God.
Immovable force versus...
Jesus.
That guy's almost in his 40s, guys.
Guys, guys, y'all be careful.
He's gonna break all the bones of his body.
You stand if you push him.
Oh, right into...
Wait, did it hit his balls?
Holy shit.
Messi was like, no kids for you.
Stay on the ground.
You gotta act harder so we can virus it.
But yeah.
Is he still on the ground?
I can't tell.
We're still in the, we're still at Switzerland's house.
We've been at Switzerland's house for like 90% of our lives.
He's still there.
He's, it doesn't matter.
It's 10 versus 11.
He's, he's going to tie his shoes real quick.
He's going to, he's just like, I'm going to go tie my shoes.
Give me.
a sec let me it's 10 v 11 the he can't fucking tie his shoes
he's still on the ground it's just taking the break bro an
argentina goalkeeper could literally just walk off the field
and Have a hydration, Brickett.
No one will know.
We've never saw that side.
We never saw that side of field.
Since.
I don't even know what the other side of the field looks
like, guys.
It's been so long.
What does it look like?
Bro, they're just doing anything.
They're just going to take as many shots as they want.
How many?
I feel like they have, there hasn't been many.
Oh, good save, though.
That was scary.
They just didn't have a guy position for it.
What's the extra time?
Guys, ref, the clock's not moving.
Oh, one minute.
Okay, I was just like, ref, the clock's has stopped.
Okay.
oh only one minute all right 10 seconds i
heard one minute no the thing is the clock didn't like they
didn't add the extra timer for my broadcast so i didn't even
know how many extra time they're adding all right nice
oh my god look
hey bro i love you bro i love you too bro hey welcome to bye
lady after this sure bro dad have i told you how much i love
you they're hugging oh they're hugging
no i love you bro
you know that the swiss's coach looks like that one guy who
played Hannibal Lector, the homo erotic Hannibal Lector guy,
who's also best friends with Kojima.
What's his name?
He looks just like him, but what if he became a football
coach?
Mads, yeah.
Mads Mickelson.
Yeah, the coach looks just like him.
Bro, their sweats were touching each other.
They were hot and sweaty, too.
Oh my god.
The wall of red.
Welcome to Switzerland.
The fucking wall of...
They cannot preach it.
Welcome to Switzerland, bro.
Now you know how World War II felt.
Now you know how they felt in World War II.
It's like trying to invade Switzerland back then.
that's the reason that's the reason why they were they get
to be neutral nobody could invade switzerland because they
were in the mountains i
hope we get penalties but i don't know it's a little hard to
tell if we're going to get penalties or not i hope we get
penalties because i haven't watched the penalties with you
guys on stream yet i think it'll be fun
oh my god everybody is roasting pronounce it?
Solar.
Oh my god, am I going to see what Argentina's goalkeeper
look like?
I haven't seen him in Solar.
Oh my god.
Please pat the camera.
I forgot what he looks like.
What does he look like?
Do they even have one?
Is there even a goalkeeper right now?
Is he in a bathroom break what does he look like is i feel
like i feel like we were in switzerland for so long it's
been 80 years since we were left in switzerland they subbed
in a make-a-wish kid on the on the field this was the
perfect time oh my god i saw him did you see him i see he
was right there guys did you
traded the goalkeeper for a 12 attacker.
There was no point in having someone that they might as
well.
Wait, I think that was the ref, Joki.
Are you sure?
Did they put in a manic in there?
The goalkeeper went home to take a nap.
They're like, call me when we win.
Oh, that That was insane.
Good DN offense there.
All right, back home.
We're going back home.
Unless...
Oh, back home, guys.
Back on home turf.
Guys, we're back home.
Construct the wall.
Take us back to the Alps.
We're back in the mountains, guys.
Grab some Swiss chocolate while you're here.
We're home.
Oh, Good seal, but there's like no one there.
Yeah, he's all on his own.
What the fuck is he going to do?
Oh, I was like, what is he going to do?
It's like one V five.
What the fuck?
I just saw one V five.
Oh, back home, back home.
We're here now.
You're all.
all right four square four square oh don't pass to that guy
bro i don't want to see that guy anymore he's just like he
missed the fucking dribble are you really bro come on
oh oh shit oh oh i told you not to pass to that guy i would
see that did i not learn That guy!
That guy does jack shit!
Oh, I mean, that was confident.
When you rush B, but nobody else follows.
Oh, I thought he hit his bass too.
I was trying to give a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for streaming, Doki.
So fun to watch with you.
Go Canada.
Mexico fan here.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Maybe in four years, we'll be back.
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay, not a...
Okay, the Swiss wall.
The Swiss mountain.
It's the Alps.
Welcome to the Alps.
Now you know how they felt.
Now you know why Swiss was a neutral country and gets to
have a choice to be neutral.
Oh, five minutes.
Good pass.
Great passes, guys.
Great pass.
The neutral wall of the outs.
What the fuck are we...
I don't fucking know.
Just give me penalties right now.
Like, at this point.
I've been watching...
I've been watching this for 30 minutes.
Oh, my God.
My timer never stopped.
I started.
sorry i just realized i had no timer where are we at i'm so
sorry i what i never i realized i never clicked start i'm
sorry where are we at someone timed this one hour and what
oh look at that this incompetent podcast still not doing
anything over there oh is he gonna
one yeah but an hour we're going by hours what a goal holy
shit what a fucking goal oh my god that was that goal was
insane that was actually an insane goal guys I need hour
time I'm gonna I'm gonna predict I think I'm here, right?
Is this where I'm at?
That is a crazy goal, though.
Is this my accurate?
No, I'm not, right?
Is this it?
It's over.
There's no way, Swiss skin.
There's no way.
Oh, am I behind?
Am I too fast forward?
two okay
what what a fucking goal holy shit oh my god that goal was
crazy oh
my god
oh it's 153 oh it is i'll restart it that's crazy see that
was an insane goal okay i think i'm right now two minutes a
minute and a half actually
wait what
what is the the wait it's a did they revoke the goal
wait what happened
what oh he just got yellow card okay okay they didn't show
what happened okay no no they kept the goal they kept the
goal but something happened yeah something happened i mean
it doesn't it's just not a 10 it's just a 10k for them it's
just yeah it's just 10k they're just like oh 10k Well,
they don't care anymore.
They have to just go in.
They, Argentina just has to solve.
That goal was beautiful, though.
Like, you guys all have to admit, that was a beautiful
fucking goal.
Like, that curve was crazy.
Like, holy, there's no, no, you cannot say that.
There's no way to say that.
That was a beautiful fucking curve.
Yeah.
it literally curved to go into the goal
i didn't unless they
yeah and it hit at the right at the corner
i mean it's like one minute left like
like cool oh my god what what that's the wall can't break
that That's a crazy shot.
Like, legitimately, that was the only way they could break
the Alps.
Nope.
Swiss's goalkeeper was crazy.
Both goalkeepers are really good.
How much is the...
How much time did I have four minutes left, right?
Is that four to five, so it should end at...
Do you think they'll have...
They should have extra time added.
Yeah, they should have extra time.
I don't know.
I don't think they're gonna score.
I would love for them to score so I could watch penalties.
I want to watch penalty kicks because I won't watch it live
on stream.
Ah, they're just gonna... They're haram.
They know.
They just have three minutes.
They can just do whatever the fuck they want.
Two minutes, technically.
It was too risky.
I would love to watch a PK but I don't think we are going to
unless Switzerland performs a miracle in a 10 v 11 situation
and I don't know I don't think so
I mean their main striker got caught out like what are they
gonna do it's literally the main striker two
minutes like what can they do oh my god they're player and
their goalkeeper is here to help out they just like it crazy
oh shit okay
that's crazy the goalkeeper had to go out
one minute I
think it'll be plus two plus two minutes plus one or plus
two minutes I don't think.
Oh my god, they all took their shirts off.
How hot is it over there?
They took their shirts off.
Oh, they're just wasting time.
Because they know they can just kick, yeah.
They're just wasting time now.
Oh hey, new ball.
That's it.
Now we can put new rules.
Hot fix.
Now we're gonna have two balls.
Two balls in play.
Each shot is double points if you get one ball in you get
double points
yeah four minutes oh four minutes damn
oh if only they had an 11 player four is
a lot they should it was like I felt like they were stalling
for so long Tuesday Wednesday and Sunday was it 14th oh
It's over.
It's tucking over.
3-1.
They altered.
Guys.
The alt has...
The alt has gone through.
A goal.
Yeah, they get a super chat.
They get that.
Yeah, I'm planning on doing the...
I'm planning on doing the other ones.
Is it Tuesday, Wednesday, and Sunday?
Oh, seven, Switzerland.
Oh, seven.
The mountains couldn't protect you this time.
The wall has, the Alps has been breached.
It's always the last 10 minutes that Argentina wakes up, I
feel like.
The faded match.
Will Miku become Argentinian?
Yeah, the goalkeeper was working so hard.
I feel, yeah, I feel like they always wake up during the
last 10 minutes of the game.
During the last 10 minutes, and then they just started
alting.
The cooldowns come up, you know?
The cooldowns.
They're still playing.
They're like, he's like, what are you doing, bro?
What are you doing?
The guy, the people at the front were still playing the
game.
I don't think I can do Saturday because I have something on
Saturday.
day but I can't do the other days I don't have any I'm
pretty sure I don't have anything on the other days because
I'm trying to organize another sloppy sisters collab uh for
next week um so we're trying to figure out what days to do
for that um we I found another restaurant simulator game
that's coming out next week
oh there's Stalin it's 15 the guy gave up he's like What's
the point?
Number 17 gave up chasing.
It was just like, what's the point?
Oh my god.
We're going to Atlanta now.
Is that where the semi is coming?
Good game.
I will say the goals, the shots were beautiful.
I think both sides had beautiful shots.
for it.
Beautiful goals for it.
I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
No, it was bad.
I would say when the wall started coming up it was a bad
game.
It was a bad game.
When they were playing murder ball I had fun.
I had fun during murder ball and then the moment was 10v11
and then they had to like bunker up.
I was, I felt like I was just let me out of Switzerland.
Like yeah I was like let me out of Switzerland please for
the love of God like get me out of get me out of this
country right now I want to I want to see what's going on
right on the other side
yeah oh yeah I when they started going like full-on bunker
mode when they parked the train and build a mountain around
the Switzerland field, that's when it started being a bad
game.
I was just not having it.
Yeah.
I was like, bro, come on, bro, come on.
They were defending really well for 10 people, though.
Like, I told you, like, Switzerland's defense is crazy.
Like, it was so frustrating to watch in person, too.
Gus, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you.
Next patch they should give the goalkeeper a sniper and now
that's very involved you're super chat thinking thank you
yeah uh and balo fucked up by at the doing that dive thank
you guys for being so so much when they began a group stage
paul i thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i
wish it was penalty though it would have been it would have
been really fun to watch um i mean they fucked up by making
the reps both canadians Like, we already have a grudge.
Like, Latino, they have a super chat.
Thank you.
I feel like they knew what they were doing when they gave...
When they put two Canadians, that's the refs.
But, like, I think, like, I think the shots were...
The shots were beautiful.
I think.
I think, like...
I think, like, the...
I think the the the shots Were like the curve was Was in the
curves between the legs Holy shit Between the legs from
Switzerland Beautiful That was a beautiful shot The curve
shot to the corner To break the wall Beautiful shot Honestly
Um Like, those two shots was, like, insane to see.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for being so entertained.
Keep me awake until 7 a.m.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, which one?
It's France versus Spain?
Alright, this is what I'm supporting.
We gotta support France, because we don't want to piss off
dictator Enbappe.
I don't want him to take me down.
As foretold by dictator Enbappe, We have to support France.
And then the dictator demands support.
And then wise choice.
And then obviously I'll be supporting England as my fellow
Commonwealth.
As our colonizer.
I shall be supporting.
I shall be supporting England versus Argentina.
Because I won France versus England.
I think that's going to be fun to watch.
England versus France.
I won England versus France.
Look, it's by royal decree.
Our head of state is still the king of England.
So what are we supposed to do?
The dictator will hear about this.
Latino, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I want to bring back the 100-year war.
We're going to bring back the classic, guys.
I call it nicer, Rizia.
So, yeah, I'm going to be rooting for England in England
versus Argentina.
Yeah, I want the modern-day 100-year war.
They've always had a rivalry, guys.
They're going to close the train.
They're going to close the train to england and france
during the game and just think about that guys when the
world cup starts they close the trains between england and
france you might even say it's a heated rivalry the hundred
minute war
guys guys hey uh sandal think it was super chat thank you
thank you uh england versus argentine is going to be
interesting we still haven't forgiven them for the half of
god gold thank you super chat thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you yeah whoever wins against
canada turkey really wants your modern day 100 year war
between england and france we're doing a throwback guys
we're bringing everything back it'll be waterloo all over
again gucabara thank you super chat thank you thank you
thank you uh nil thank you super chat thank you thank you go
france the french already made an unofficial banger song
chat thank you thank you i will um i will say that i think i
think i'm looking forward to i'm looking forward to watching
england versus argentina i think i don't know much about
spain's team i just didn't have a lot of background
knowledge of spain's team because i haven't done any
watchlines of spain or haven't watched any of the spain
games um i know france because of all the memes about embape
i heard that he what did he do he did he sent like a cease
and desist letter to like somebody's cake or some shit i
don't remember exactly but oh yeah sorry about the timer
um but what was it that's all i yeah that's all i need to
know he said like someone made a birthday cake um with on
there and then he got yeah he got sent the Mbappe special
where he got sent a cease and desist because he used his he
used his picture
Duke of Bellingham versus dictator Mbappe MRK thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you
that's where the memes come from wait dictator because
Mbappe that's why everyone calls him
all right let's see
yeah all right he sued a so it first became a thing because
um he sued a uh merci-based influencer and kebab shop owner
who used his name in the description of one of his
sandwiches
and then they're like dictator imbappe
there's a song too and also you watch any clips of imbappe I
think that's what happened to...
Um...
And then, like, uh, XQC watched, like, a couple of seconds
of a BAPE clips on his stream, and then BAPE took his stream
down.
He got, like, he got suspended on Twitch for, like, a day or
some shit.
Like...
Yeah.
Dictated on BAPE.
Uh, Tino, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
He said delete this.
Yeah, yeah, he got suspended on Twitch because he watched a
couple of minutes of Mbappe clips or something.
He's always watching.
I have to support France.
I'm sorry, guys.
But when it's France versus England, that's going to be
hard.
If it comes to France versus England, it's going to be hard.
I don't know.
It's like, Canada is half French and half English.
And it's like a custody battle for Canada too.
So, I haven't shown any pictures on I haven't shown any
pictures on stream of Mbappe The 100 minute war He's already
liked Mbappe You don't have to sell on me Lightning Thank
you for the super chat Thank you thank you I don't know I
don't know What the final I personally would want the final
to be To be the 100 minute war I personally want that Wanted
to be that Just because I think it's funnier I
I just think it's funnier if it's like England versus France
just because the memes that are born from it would be much
more funny it's the funniest option the hundred minute war
is funnier Lego thank you super chat thank you thank you God
saved the dokey from
the I'm on board with the 100 minute war.
But yeah, those were, these were interesting games.
It's like half, half.
I won't say they were like great games.
I will say they were like interesting.
They had like some fun moments.
There were like moments in there that was like pretty good.
But then there were like moments in there that fucking were
like so sluggish.
Oh my God.
Like, it didn't help with the England versus Norway.
Like, half of Norway's teams were...
Half of Norway's team was sick.
And then it was hot and humid for both teams.
So the games felt so sloppy to watch in general.
Like, some of the...
But there were, like, some crazy moments there in terms of,
like, you know...
And some, like, drama, I would say.
There was a lot of drama in it.
And but like Argentina versus Switzerland there was so much
drama and then I felt like I was locked into Swiss I was
like I I felt like I got like uh, they took away my passport
and I was stuck in Switzerland for like 60 minutes
And that's what I was like, please let me out.
Let me the fuck out Please I can't keep I can't keep being
in Switzerland.
I Please I thought I was locked in Switzerland for 60
minutes.
I just, just 60, honestly, if, honestly, maybe like 80
No, even more, never mind.
90 minutes of Switzerland.
They were a football fan, or I mean, watch it, but you sure
I made some things very fun.
You have great commentary.
Thanks for the games.
Thank you, the super chat, son.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, and then, and then they suddenly hot-pashed it.
And then Argentina got two back-to-back yellow cards because
they finally realized that that all their offshore accounts
are located in Switzerland and they're like, oh fuck.
They're like, shit, we got to start giving yellow cards or
we're going to get audited.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, 90 minutes of pure neutrality.
Yeah.
Oh no, that third goal was ass.
No, never mind.
Third goal was shit.
First, third goal from, yeah, first and second goal from
Argentina was sick as hell.
Third goal was pretty bad.
If only Switzerland knew about the acting patch.
Guys, they haven't been this far in years, guys.
They forgot.
They forgot to get acting classes.
Third was just a bonus on top.
Yeah.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Every top buddy talks about France, England, or France,
Argentina.
But Spain, Argentina would be our second independence war.
If we lose, we are a colony again.
Oh, gosh.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, Duke does the answer.
Yeah.
Their best knockout stage performance?
Were we watching the same game?
This was their best.
There's no way.
This is their best knockout performance.
Bro, it's a 10v11.
That was...
a 10v11 bro like what the fuck do you mean what are these
casters saying
but uh when is the england versus argentina game yeah imbala
fucked up though imbala fucked up there they had he actually
fucked over his team for that
tuesday tuesday oh wednesday okay i was gonna say there's no
way it's juesday France because like they just finished the
game they're showing the drive-by the hidden run drive-by
the a tree
so I'm listening to the casting right now but
the different angle is crazy bro that dive was okay the dive
in the different angle was actually fucking hilarious
because you can see you can see it like that nothing touched
him like yeah that's crazy because then like they show they
i sit in the casting they showed a different angle where
it's like the front view and he was literally it was nothing
yeah he got pushed by mosquito or some shit that's
crazy i'm getting a slow-mo recapture right now.
it's because the Argentina guy, he was running so fast, he
was breaking the speed of sound.
Wait, we're gonna find out Wednesday if there is a Miku
curse.
Guys, if England loses, the real witch was Miku all along.
Every team that has Miku has lost so far.
So the real if England loses, then we all know Who the real
witch was?
Wait, I'm gonna tweet that.
It may be the real witch was Miku all along.
Every country had Miku lost.
All right,
always, always has been.
We're going to find out on Wednesday, guys.
If England loses, the curse is passed down to Argentina.
Think about it.
If England loses, it went, every country has held Miku one
time.
They've only held Miku one time.
Miku, Miku, and Fana.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
Oh, my gosh.
I need to rest my voice.
I've been yelling and screaming until I've been drinking a
lot of water.
Thank you, guys, for coming with me to another watchalong.
I had a great time doing these watchalongs.
There's something new.
Something new, and they're done before.
And, like, it's been really...
It's been an absolute blast.
watching football with all of you guys um throughout the
these matches um and we're gonna you know i fucking
subscribe to craves so like i might as well make a good use
of the the amount of the money i paid for it this month um
any guys thank you all for watching on me as always
everybody say hi during the posture check get up and move
around to get that blood flowing and if you suffer me head
to bed because you deserve it i hope you guys been enjoying
the all the fifa streams um i know like some of you guys i i
was worried about doing these watch lines because obviously
like you know it takes over my other streams that i do but i
hope you guys still enjoy them even though i'm not playing a
game or anything and i'm just like um and you have to pull
up the games off of another stream because i don't want to
get hit by the world by fifa i don't want to get struck down
by fifa but i'm glad you guys have been enjoying it hey guys
as always everybody uh stay hydrated posture check yeah but
move around and get that blood flowing stand for me head to
bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody 100%.
I have 100% prediction rate right now, guys.
100%.
Bye-bye, everyone.
Bye.